do we all learn languages the same way
the quick answer is yes but I can refine
that answer a little bit our brains
learn the same way we all have more or
less similarly structured brains just
like our digestive system works the same
in every person now it may be that we
like certain foods and we don't like
other Foods or we live in an area where
there's lots of fish and so we tend to
consume things that are available to us
or things that we like to consume in our
stomachs in our digestive system the
same is true in our brains some people
like reading and some people don't like
reading some people can't read some
people have problems with their eyes
some people are dyslexic some people are
visually impaired or auditorily impaired
so obviously they are going to absorb
the language in whatever way suits their
capability but if we have people who are
equally able to see equally able to here
then essentially they're going to
process language input in the same way
some people may prefer speaking to
listening or reading but that doesn't
mean they learn by speaking the only way
we can learn a new language that is a
language that we don't have in ourselves
is to get the language from outside
ourselves input and that means listening
if we are able to hear reading if we are
able to see and read a combination of
both which is ideal because the more
different ways we can acquire the same
information the better we're going to
learn that information but the process
is the same now if you Google does
everyone learn the same way you'll find
a bunch of Articles scholarly articles
from Educators saying that we all learn
differently we have visual Learners and
auditory Learners and kinetic learners
but in fact there is no scientific
research which supports this in fact
when they ask people what kind of
learner they are and people say I'm a
visual learner and I'm an auditory
learner and so forth and then they put
them in separate groups and have them
learn something there's no difference
whether that person learns in the way
they think they are more inclined to
learn the way they think their brain
works and someone who is learning in a
way which in theory they said I'm not a
visual learner it's all the same so
that's just a myth and I'm going to
leave a link to some articles on the
subject but it becomes a bit of a crutch
so I only can learn things if I hear
them in fact we all learn better if we
both read and listen when it comes to
languages speaking of course in order to
speak well we need to speak a lot and
part of speaking is that we then
generate input that's relevant to us
because it's from the person we're
speaking to and who want to learn that
and so it's an important part of the
input process is speaking with people
and of course an important part of
practicing speaking is speaking and in
my previous videos I explained this
steps that the brain goes through in
drawing on its memory of the language
and is experience with the language in
order to generate an utterance in the
language but language learning starts
with getting the language in you and we
all do it the same way but there are two
other things that should be considered
when we say do we learn the same way one
is our preferences so some people simply
don't like to read so if a person
doesn't like to read because our
motivation is so important in language
learning than to push against something
that person doesn't like to do is going
to be counterproductive so in that sense
it's a good thing to allow people to
learn in the way they find the most
Pleasant because then they're most
likely to continue and put the effort in
however it shouldn't be used as a crutch
I can't learn by reading no that's not
true if you develop the habit of reading
you will learn through Reading and that
will reinforce the learning you're doing
through listening another consideration
is sort of the level we are in the
language obviously at the very beginning
it's very difficult to start speaking we
have very little to say and if we rely
on our ability to speak we simply go
round and round using the same words all
the time so at the beginning stage it's
more important to do a lot of listening
and reading in order to build up some
experience some memories some knowledge
of the language if we're at an
intermediate stage so now we're in this
particular language we want to speak we
want to speak well so we have
accumulated now some resources some
words some phrases some experience with
the language we want to get out and use
it so therefore we need to speak more so
at that stage the speaking activity
should become more important so at
different stages in our journey in a
particular language certain activities
may be more important maybe preferred an
activity which is preferred is probably
going to be better because the student
the learner is Keen to do these things
but it's important to not get carried
away with certain educational fads like
the idea that we have different learning
styles and this myth of the learning
styles is still strongly held and it
seems kind of intuitive but any
scientific research on the subject has
shown that in fact it's simply a myth so
obviously if we have a strong preference
for a certain learning activity that's
what we're going to do and as long as we
are motivated and we spend the time with
the language we are going to learn but
we shouldn't fool ourselves into
thinking that some people will only
learn if they hear the language that
others will only learn if they read the
language or they will only learn if they
speak the language in fact all of our
brains function more or less the same
way and it's a subject of great interest
to me because I'm doing all this reading
on how the brain learns different things
but we all basically just as we have
essentially the same digestive system we
have the same cerebral system so yeah
the quick answer is we all learn the
same way with a few caveats that I
mentioned